you are about to watch an episode of my
awesome new
series debunked if i do say so myself
seriously we are very proud of
this show every episode i dismantle and
debunk a common leftist myth
in 15 minutes or less if you like what
you see head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code debunk for 20
off become a member today
because you can watch the entire first
season right this instant that is
correct you can binge the entire first
season right now on the daily wire go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code debunked for 20
off enjoy
this sneak peek today on debunked we're
going to discuss
a very common question can a man be a
woman
dr levine do you believe that minors are
capable of making such a life-changing
decision as changing one's sex
well senator thank you for your interest
in this question um transgender medicine
is a very complex and nuanced field
the specific question was about minors
let's be a little more specific since
you evaded the question
do you support the government
intervening to override the parent's
consent
to give a child puberty blockers
cross-sex hormones
and or amputation surgery of breasts and
genitalia
senator transgender medicine is a very
complex
the answer clearly is yes as levine even
told a former trump administration
official
just pause on that for a moment and
think about how crazy that is
now the past few years you've heard a
lot of statements that sound like we
must not raise boys as boys and girls as
girls
because we just can't be sure that kids
actually have the sex
assigned to them at birth
you've heard that some people are men in
women's bodies
or women in men's bodies you may even
have heard that if you're a straight
dude and you don't want to have sex with
a trans woman
meaning a biological male this makes you
gay
all of this is insane patent nonsense
males and females reproduce with one
another in the human species
we've known this for quite a while the
simple reality is that the human species
is sexually dimorphic
sex is binary we come in two brands male
and female typically those who have the
x y chromosomes are male
those who have x chromosomes are female
males and females differ they differ in
size and shape musculature
brain function as neuroscientist stephen
pinker says
differences between the sexes are part
of the human condition
there are certainly people who have
anomalous genetic conditions like
klinefelter syndrome
in which a person has two x chromosomes
and a y chromosome
and in whom breast development looks
female while male genitalia are present
overall disorders of sexual development
affect one in every five thousand births
now the presence of abnormal development
does not mean that sex is a
spectrum to suggest otherwise it would
be the same thing as saying
that because one child every few
thousand is born with three toes
this means that the number of toes in
the human being is a spectrum
or that a person with three toes might
actually be a sloth
human a three-toed sloth human
all reproduction is rooted in the
presence of sexual dimorphism
to pretend otherwise is biologically
nonsensical
that's why to end a conversation on
transgenderism just ask for a simple
non-self-referential definition of the
terms man
and woman when i say
non-self-referential i mean you can't
say
i feel like a woman therefore i am a
woman for advocates of biology
the answer for what is woman or what is
man
is simple you can look at chromosomes
sry genes
reproductive systems verifiable answers
to the question
for advocates of the position that some
biological men are women
or vice versa there is no
standard that can be applied a man can
become a woman
or a woman a man at any time without any
stable definition
of man or woman whatsoever
[Music]
so according to our pseudo-medical
activists gender identity
is completely separate from sex the
separation between gender
and sex relies on a simple fallacy that
gender is entirely socially constructed
and thus separate from biology gender
in this iteration would be all the
various feminine qualities
that adhere to womanhood or the
masculine qualities
that adhere to being a male according to
these folks
gender and sex are completely different
all of those
gendered notions of femininity they're
completely separate from being a
biological female
this cartesian notion that you can be a
woman in a man's body
a soul in the machine because your
gender is separate from your sex
is utterly unsupportable at any level
everyone understands there are some
attributes that are generally considered
more masculine
chopping wood
[Music]
being dumb i'm whizzing with the door
open
and i love it and some that are
considered more feminine
being caring being nice right these are
distinctions that do appear
in virtually all cultures some of that
is undoubtedly biologically oriented and
some
is undoubtedly social construction but
it is simply ridiculous to suggest that
if a boy is effeminate
he's actually a girl or that if a girl
is masculine
she might actually be a boy but this is
what gender theorists
argue
[Music]
the origins of the gender identity
movement lie with a professor of medical
psychology at johns hopkins in the 1960s
his name was john money
after twin boys were born and after a
botched circumcision destroyed one boy's
penis
that boy was raised as a girl
by the time that boy was a teenager the
boy felt extraordinary discomfort
because he was biologically male
and his parents told him the truth
both twins ended up killing themselves
in their mid-30s
that didn't stop john money from
founding the johns hopkins gender
identity clinic in 1965.
his theory was children could identify
as members of the opposite sex
and that radical surgery was the proper
solution
that inside these kids were members of
the opposite sex in reality
and that surgery would merely make their
bodies align with their identity
money claims that quote the gender
identity gate is open at birth for a
normal child
no less than for one born with
unfinished sex organs and would stay
that way for at least a year
so in other words you could have a full
biological boy
with finished sex organs and his gender
identity was still open
brains and bodies were considered in
direct opposition completely separate
from one another
radical feminists like judith butler
began arguing that all gender was
socially constructed
and that therefore all inequalities and
outcome between men and women
could be laid at the feet of an evil
sexist society
if gender is a meaningless social
construct created by society
why does it matter more than sex which
is actual real biology
and why is gender more real than biology
itself why would anyone need to change
his or her body
in order to align with gender a social
construction
when gender and sex are completely
separate in the first place
gender dysphoria which is what we're
talking about here is a serious and
tragic disorder it is also extremely
rare
according to the diagnostic and
statistical manual 5th edition those who
had received a diagnosis of gender
identity disorder or transsexualism
and were seeking hormone treatment and
or surgery represented just
.005 to 0.014 percent for males
and zero two two point zero zero three
percent
for females those stats are now rising
dramatically
we have that big announcement from an
oscar-nominated actor announcing he is
transgender eliot page came out publicly
with a post about his identity and in
that post now liked nearly two and a
half million times the more i hold
myself close and fully embrace who i am
the more i dream the more my heart grows
and the more i thrive and guys
that's what we love to see yes he is
going to help so many janae
thank you so much people suffering from
gender dysphoria which in its
non-politicized definition
means the persistent belief that you are
a member of the opposite sex
have a tragically high suicidal ideation
and depression rate
that suicidal ideation rate remains
tragically high
after surgical and hormonal treatment
longitudinal studies that are good just
do not exist on the efficacy of these
measures
and the mental health problems
associated with gender dysphoria remain
extremely damaging even in particularly
accepting societies but suffering from a
mental disorder does not change
your underlying sex any more than
believing that you are napoleon
bonaparte makes you napoleon bonaparte
transgender activists make an objective
claim about reality based on subjective
internal
feelings that's unsustainable what's
more
transgender activists demand that you
abandon reason
biology privacy even the ability to
raise your kids
in concert with reality in favor of a
delusional quasi-religious worldview in
which gender and sex are completely
segregated and
a boy can be a girl and a girl a boy
[Music]
now none of this means that anybody
suffering from gender dysphoria ought to
be mistreated
anybody with any sort of disorder ought
to be treated with nothing but sympathy
and care
but this does mean that a society that
seeks to propagandize to children that
they can switch their gender is both
lying to kids
and doing them psychological harm in the
process
unfortunately that's exactly what our
society is now teaching kids in public
schools
anti-biological nonsense including the
lie that you might just be a different
gender with different pronouns
and it's not just that with the new
equality act the motion is adopted
the biden administration and the
democratic party are seeking to promote
the idea that any institution that
doesn't mimic these lies
has to be destroyed religious
institutions are not exempted from
federal regulations it's a man that men
who identify as women be treated as
women and this is true in sports
in restrooms ironically feminists who
sought to protect women from men
have now seen female spaces completely
destroyed because they can't define
female and male properly most shockingly
we're now a society that demands that
parents hand over their kids to the
tender mercies of political actors
masquerading as medical specialists
if you have a 12 year old at school with
a headache the school nurse cannot
prescribe to them tylenol without
calling you first but
we now have officials in states and in
the federal government
suggesting that if a 12 year old says
that she is a boy
the school should be able to prescribe
puberty blockers without calling a
parent
that is a sick society
in the end a man claiming to be a woman
is making an unsustainable claim he
can't even know what it is like to be a
woman
because he is not one a man with
surgeries and hormone treatment does not
become a woman
nor does a man who simply declares
himself a woman
all of this is insane propaganza is
being propagated for political purposes
so no a man cannot become a woman or a
woman a man
alrighty folks if you enjoyed this
episode go get the entire first season
right now at the daily wire there are 10
episodes available right now you can get
the full collection of my show notes
over there too
with the links and resources to all the
data i used all in one place but
only when you become a member so become
a member today go to dailywire.com
subscribe use promo code debunked for 20
off